tenemos la pregunta si todo lo demás se
mantiene constante cuál de las
siguientes opciones provocaría que la
producción agregada aumente pausa el
vídeo y piensa en cuál de estas opciones
lo haría
muy bien vamos a trabajar juntos la
primera dice más personas ingresan a la
fuerza laboral mientras que la tasa de
desempleo se mantiene constante bueno la
fuerza laboral es un factor importante
de la producción y si más personas
entran a la fuerza laboral y la tasa de
desempleo se mantiene constante entonces
aumenta el valor absoluto de las
personas que ahí trabajan y si todo lo
demás se mantiene constante que es justo
lo que nos dicen acá arriba es decir el
nivel de tecnología el capital la
productividad por persona entonces
esperar a que aumente la producción por
lo tanto la producción agregada aumenta
en este escenario y voy a poner una
marca para decir que si en este
escenario si aún
ok la segunda dice la velocidad del
dinero aumenta esta es bastante
tentadora ya que seguramente asocia una
velocidad del dinero alta es decir hay
un montón de transacciones con una gran
economía positiva pero recuerda estamos
pensando un escenario donde todo lo
demás se mantiene constante tal vez
existe un escenario donde la gente haga
más transacciones el dinero circula más
rápido pero la cantidad total de
producción no ha cambiado del todo
tenemos la misma cantidad de empleados
produciendo los mismos bienes usando la
misma tecnología y teniendo el mismo
capital por lo tanto este inciso no
tiene un vínculo directo con el aumento
de la producción agregada si todo lo
demás se mantiene constante así que voy
a cancelarla el número 3 dice la
inflación aumenta
de nuevo es un inciso tentador porque en
muchas ocasiones cuando producimos con
mucha rapidez cuando la economía es
fuerte entonces asociamos esto a una
inflación alta pero existen muchos casos
en la historia donde tienes
hiperinflación cuando la economía en
realidad se contrae de nuevo recuerda
que nos piden que todo lo demás se
mantenga constante por lo tanto tenemos
una situación en donde el nivel de
presión y la tasa de inflación aumentan
pero producimos los mismos bienes y
servicios
entonces en definitiva cancelaré también
esta opción número 4 se desarrolla un
nuevo método para producir más bienes
con los mismos recursos
bueno aquí imagina un escenario muy
simple si toda la economía consiste en
mí y yo produzco lápices imagina que
puede no ser producir diez lápices al
día y descubro un nuevo método que me
permite producir 20 lápices al día con
los mismos recursos
sigo siendo solo yo con el mismo acceso
a la madera y las mismas herramientas
entonces drásticamente estoy
incrementando mi producción agregada una
forma de pensar esto es que mi nivel de
tecnología aumentó lo cual es un factor
importante de la producción por lo tanto
pondré una marca de que en efecto
aumenta mi producción agregada muy bien
se construyen 10 granjas nuevas si se
construyen nuevas granjas y suponemos
que se usarán entonces tendremos más
producción y eso hará que crezcan más
cosas el nivel de capital aumentó y una
vez más este es un factor importante
para la producción así que también voy a
marcarla
muy bien las importaciones aumentan
bueno las importaciones nos dan una
ventaja en el comercio pero nos da la
producción de otra persona eso no habla
de lo que sucede a nuestra producción
por lo tanto no es una opción correcta y
voy a cancelarla
y todo esto es bastante intuitivo
estamos hablando de factores para
aumentar la producción como la fuerza de
trabajo la tecnología y el capital los
economistas suelen contar todos estos
factores de producción y nos muestran
cómo conduce nuestra producción agregada
con una función llamada la función de
producción agregada déjame escribir la
función de producción agregada y parece
que tenemos un conjunto elegante de
palabras y lo que intentará escribir acá
abajo aparecerán como matemáticas
elegantes pero como veremos es bastante
intuitivo la función de producción
agregada nos dice que nuestra producción
es igual
am puedes ver a am como una medida de la
tecnología y es conocida como
productividad total de los factores otra
palabra elegante por una función esta es
la razón del por qué pienso que es
elegante ya que estamos en una anotación
de funciones por una función de nuestro
capital cam y ya sé que capital no
empieza con camps en el espanyol y
además de la fuerza laboral y si todo
esto es demasiado abstracto si queremos
hacerlo más tangible en especial este
uso de notaciones de funciones podemos
decir que nuestra producción agregada va
a ser igual
esta app que es la productividad total
de los factores y bueno me tomaré una
función se me ocurre la función
raíz cuadrada de k que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada de
pero en general como puedes ver en este
ejemplo las funciones de producción
agregada se ven algo parecido la raíz
cuadrada o algunos radicales en el
capital en la fuerza del trabajo tal vez
haya una pequeña diferencia pero nos
dice la misma historia si incrementas tu
nivel de tecnología incrementará su
producción agregada si incrementas tu
capital incrementará su producción
agregada y se incrementa su fuerza de
trabajo incrementará su producción
agregada y la razón del por qué verás
estas raíces cuadradas o exponentes
fraccionarios en el capital y en la
fuerza del trabajo es la idea de los
rendimientos marginales decrecientes es
decir realmente la primera granja te da
un montón de tus producciones y tal vez
la millonésima granja app te siga dando
una producción pero en un nivel menor de
igual manera las 10 primeras personas
agregando un montón de producción pero
después de 10 millones de personas
10 seguirán agregando a la producción
pero no tanto eso es lo que te dicen
estos modelos matemáticos entonces el
modelo general es bastante intuitivo si
mantenemos todos los demás constante e
incrementan los factores de tu
producción entonces aumentarán tu
producción agregada ahora bien como a
los economistas les gusta describir las
cosas de una manera matemática entonces
tenemos una función agregada muy bien
ahora por último pero no menos
importante una idea relacionada con la
función de la producción agregada es la
idea de productividad déjame escribirlo
ya hemos visto que am es la
productividad total de los factores
realmente nos hablan de una medida de la
tecnología en la economía cuando las
personas hablan de una productividad
hablan de la producción per cápita es
decir de la producción por persona
lo que realmente están pensando es en la
producción agregada jeff entre la fuerza
laboral el esto nos dará la producción
promedio por persona y observa si la
tecnología aumenta y la fuerza laboral
es constante entonces tu producción por
persona también aumentará si tenemos una
fuerza de labor constante pero tu
capital aumenta lo que ya sabemos que
aumentarán su producción entonces la
productividad también lo hará por
persona serás capaz de producir más en
tu economía
por ahora me despido nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo